[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you guys ready to go to the Great Dismal
Swamp yeah I was about 10 o'clock at
night and Becca's upstairs in the hotel
putting the kids down and I'm just
tightening up the boat so none of my
rods disappear our fishing trip has hit
a little bit of snag the boys have
discovered Saturday morning cartoons you
guys will go fishing you just want sit
and watch cartoons all day oh the boys
are trying to torment mommy with
thoughts of the future well guys we're
here we're in the Great Dismal Swamp
[Applause]
we're late Drummond well here we are
guys lake Drummond one of two natural
lakes here in Virginia every other Lake
here in Virginia is a reservoir man-made
alright so I got a little problem with
the boat ramp here this is a really
shallow boat ramp and I backed up as far
as I dare get my car and it's not quite
deep enough to float the boat so I'm
just trying to push it off because I
know once I get it off it's much easier
to get back on because they got the
winch oh that is sweet that comes in
three pieces and it's a tandem right
yeah oh so you just remove the middle
section and just put the back end and
the company's point 65 is that the
company or the model good seats to we're
just barely floating alright we're
sitting in diddly-squat feet of water
and we're gonna see if we could do this
without destroying my prop you don't
know what you're doing do it slowly
I've got about a foot and a half two
feet of water underneath my pontoons
here so look how brown the water is
there we go the water temperature is 76
and like two feet
[Music]
lovely day though isn't it
this lake is really fascinating it's
pretty large very acidic and shallow and
there's not much going on it I've seen a
few things jump here and there but I'm
not really seeing much of anything on
the fishfinder but they're supposed to
be panfish gar and bowfin and some small
catfish in here so we're gonna see what
we can find the absolute deepest part of
this lake is 6 feet deep so I could
literally walk across this entire lake
well this place is a little bit of a
time machine this is what from about BC
down to Florida
looked like along the East Coast it was
lowland swamp Cypress forests yeah this
is it and we're getting the fish for
actual native species we got four
freaking feet of water here look at this
and we're getting a lot of structure on
the bottom some of this flooded timber
oh this is pretty this is this is what I
was hoping for well you have a match
hold still you have a massive bug on
your throat well it's kind of near the
middle of the day so the pan fish were
gonna be close into the shelter so I'm
gonna snuggle right in here to the trees
then we're gonna drop some ink here okay
so we're gonna go ahead and drop some
bobbers with worms and see if we can't
catch some pan fish then it'll chunk up
a few of those and see if we can't catch
them both in the dark I'm pretty excited
it's not often I get to go fishing with
my wife
so I've busted out her pink little
ultralight here nice little bowl head
right there first fish of the day didn't
take very long that's a good omen hey
you know I wasn't hooking him and a
rusted piece of a fishhook came out of
his mouth
there we go another bull head another
native species here in Virginia
this lake right here is one of the only
places in Virginia that I know of that
only has native species there isn't a
single non native species here which is
really interesting if you think about it
because you know I like carp fishing and
everyone's like Oh carp there and
they're not native here they're invasive
well pretty much every fish that we
target is not native around here in
Virginia
I mean bull heads Garbo fin pumpkinseed
bluegill those are our native species
well we've been here about 30 minutes
and we're fishing for rods with worms
now if we get on the bottom we're
hitting bull heads pretty quick but
under bobbers we're not getting diddly
squat you know I can't remember the last
time I fished with worms under a bobber
and didn't get a bluegill really quick
so we'll we'll kind of see we might have
to try some different spots this is an
unusual Lake I really want to catch a
bow fin and some gar and I'm gonna need
some bait to do that so I gotta find
some pan fish and this place is fall
ball heads no pan fish so we're gonna
move on
explore this Lake a little bit more this
place is really amazing look at this
these cypress trees that is that girl
well we're just here in another spot
drifting along see if we can't pick up a
bite well every time I relay my bait
something's taking bites out of the worm
I mean there's something little out
there this is the number 12 hook and
it's too big but there's there's
probably some minnows or something out
there hitting this pretty fish alright
this is the entrance to the eastern
canal which you can see is only
accessible by kayak or canoe but we're
gonna post up right here and see if we
can't catch something we just caught
that little black crappie right here so
we're gonna we're gonna try it and see
if we can't catch something else
check this out is a little baby bull
head but when I when I was reeling him
up about a 24 inch catfish came up and
followed him so I'm gonna go put this
back and see if we can't catch something
bigger believe these are black bull
heads check this out this is the channel
catfish she's got a forked tail but oh
he's he's stunted well the kids are a
little bit hot hungry and fussy so we're
gonna call it go home but we've caught a
bunch of black bull heads a bluegill a
channel cat and a bye crappie so not not
too bad and we just had a great time
[Music]
got the trailer in as deep as it goes as
you can see the trailer is not
underwater now is breathing full
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
look at that
he vibrates his tail that was so cool
well guys you join your ice cream well
thanks for watching guys we hope you
enjoyed our video we had a great time
and thanks for coming along with us if
you want to see more great videos from
the outdoor boys YouTube channel don't
forget to please subscribe yeah that's
right if you like this video don't
forget to check out the outdoor boys
YouTube channel where we have hundreds
of videos just like this and don't
forget to click subscribe so you can see
other great videos every Saturday
morning and hit that Bell button so
you'll get notifications thanks for
watching